so I think the the best place to actually start is I was actually one of
those people who became Muslim like on my own literally 20 years ago um on New
Year's Eve I after looking at Islam and studying and reflecting actually on it for a
many years at least three years I like finally took that leap to like make the
sh to actually
say and I did that all alone in my room and for at least four or
five months I actually really just had that experience of being alone um I knew why
I chose to be Muslim I had no doubts in I see doing it but there
was definitely something clearly missing and I would actually make it analogous to um actually track
so if you ever been to a track meet before you actually look and you'll see
that in the track meet there's so many things actually going on at any given time
there's a lot of events going on and actually there'll be the idea of a team
that's one team versus another team versus another team right but if you really look at
it there's a lot of individual successes and failures just really going on there somebody can
actually their team might be able to win the event but there could be somebody who
played a lot better in one particular particular part part of sport whether that be shot
put whether that be how they jumped whether be how they ran so in a way
it's like there's there could be a lot of chaos when you actually look at the
sport and there's a lot of like aloneness and so that's what I was I was
like a Muslim almost like got attract me I was very much alone in my experience
and I didn't actually have the sense of community and the biggest piece of actually a
shift for me where life actually became different was when I actually finally went to the
mosque and believe it or not it was because somebody who I was friends with and
I didn't even know he was Muslim at the time he said he had gone to
this particular mosque so actually took the trk and walked to this mosque and after walking
to this mosque and actually after having just so many years of wanting to become Muslim
want to actually really know am I really a Muslim do I like really belong I
actually had to sit down with somebody in the mosque and actually even wasn't like an
Imam or some big figure it was actually just somebody who was at the mosque at
the time who um was a professional he just sat down with me and he answered
all my questions I was asking him some basic questions about em man about belief and
in that one moment in that 40 minutes or 20 minutes that that man gave me
in that conversation I actually just felt like this sense of of Peace really come come
over me and a sense of yeah almost like a sense of belonging and from then
on it's like I got introduced to his children and actually started going to the mosque
and then I really started getting a sense of actually that aspect of the peace that
actually was in
Islam because without that aspect of the community without that aspect of actually being actually in
in that group you never really get to experience the real flow and the part that
was so interesting is I had spent so much time reading books about how to pray
about how to practice the five pillars of Islam and it was like within five or
10 minutes being able to watch what some other people were doing being able to be
around other people being able to have a conversation about what other people were doing I
was able to get a a a higher level and a higher sense of the dean
in such a short period of time and that to me actually speaks to the power
of companionship the power of actually being able to be around somebody else and the impact
that actually has it's it's even a concept or an idea even in the social sciences
that it's not just like one person plus one person just equals to but actually the
group actually as you add each person it has its own Spirit it has its own
flavor just if you even think about movements when people actually came together whether I mean
to like uh for empowerment of of African-American
like when people come together there's a spirit that actually comes over the group there's a
spirit that actually comes all of its own that's not just 1 plus one plus one
plus one but it's actually a group actually has a spirit of its own and to
me that's actually one of the key aspects of Islam a key aspects of peace and
that's why it's so powerful and important to actually just be in the group and be
able to actually have companionship in Islam to actually come through some levels it's often been
said like you know you look and you'll say okay I'm here how is it that
I actually can get to another place and the idea in Islam is very much like
the idea in any other place like if you want to be a successful businessman you
start hanging out with who successful businessman right so it's almost like the same idea as
you want to learn and grow in in your Islam how do you do that you
actually spend your time around and inside the community and I would say that that actually
is is a central piece to the other part that I actually really want to talk
about which is the importance of knowledge of Islam like so I feel like there's a
place where um a person actually is not going to experience the other level of Islam
um which actually has to do with peace as well if they actually don't have knowledge
like anybody if you've ever cooked something if you've ever like went through the procedure of
something knowing actually how to do it yourself gives you a sense of security gives you
a sense of confidence that that nothing else like really can no matter how well you
actually might follow something no matter how well that you actually might like look at somebody
and go right behind them there's a different sense that you actually have when you know
what's about to come next even if you're following when you when you actually know okay
so this person turns this way I know I know like because of my own GPS
for example if I'm actually following somebody and I have my own GPS I still have
a security okay I know this is the route that's supposed to go and that's actually
in a sense the power of actually learning and studying in the religion the idea of
you actually ever belonging or you actually feeling like this Dean is is is like this
big elepant and like being afraid to actually or not knowing if you actually really belong
that experience is never really going to go away unless you actually really start taking some
steps to really start to know what it is that that God is actually asking in
particular of you what it is that God is actually asking in particular of the community
because there's different levels of things that a person is actually asked to do and and
that will again come about when you actually seek it out and Company so actually as
you spend time in the community you start knowing actually who is the more knowledgeable person
who is the type of person that you actually want to Aspire to and that in
of itself will un fold the type of people that you really want to be around
amongst the groups of Muslims that actually are there that actually will help guide you to
being more secure in yourself and having that sense of Peace about your religion and so
in that same vein it really talks about the importance of the conversation that's going to
take on take place on April 17th at Ruckus University it's an opportunity to actually come
together as Muslims and be able to taste from the number of convers that are actually
out there and be able to have a conversation about some of the concerns that exist
some of the things that we struggle with as we actually go through our Islam and
be able for you to find that group that individual maybe even just one person make
the network network with one person that's going to have it so that your Islam can
go from where it is and be able to build and go along to a place
where you get a higher sense of Peace because that's just really what I believe the
heart of this religion is really about